ah
y
la zona de frontera entre colombia y
panamá es una ruta importante para el
tránsito de migrantes que viajan hacia
méxico o eeuu o canadá pero esta no es
una ruta nueva y en los últimos años se
ha reportado el tránsito masivo de
migrantes por esta zona estamos hablando
de emigrantes haitianos procedentes
algunos de ellos de chile o brasil
algunos africanos venezolanos con
cubanos y asiáticos en la última semana
del mes de julio se reportó el
represamiento en esta localidad en
necoclí una zona del noroccidente de
colombia de al menos 15 mil migrantes
que no podían salir de este municipio
ante la falta de transporte marítimo que
los llevará hasta la población vecina de
capurganá preocupa mucho en este lugar
la situación de miles de mujeres que
viajan algunas solas con menores de
brazos pero después de que los migrantes
pasan colombia les queda cruzar la selva
del darién una selva intransitable y
peligrosa y que algunos de los migrantes
que ya han logrado cruzar hacia panamá
dicen que son testigos de algunos robos
violaciones
el gobierno de panamá informó que sólo
en el mes de julio fueron recibidos 19
mil migrantes por esta región
así es méxico sigue siendo principal
puerta de entrada de cruce indocumentado
también a los eeuu el instituto nacional
de migración en méxico advierte que hay
cerca de 35 mil ciudadanos en el país
que están de forma indocumentada en el
2016 al menos aquí en baja california
estado donde inicia la patria en la zona
norte desde luego llegaron muchos muchos
haitianos que permanecen hasta la fecha
intentando cruzar hacia los estados
unidos dos años después se registra la
llamada caravana de migrantes residentes
principalmente de honduras de guatemala
y del salvador son quienes permanecen
desde entonces aquí en la región ahora
se ha sumado este campamento de
migrantes que están en condiciones
difíciles intentando intentar no tocar
el corazón de las autoridades
norteamericanas para conseguir el
llamado asilo político y tener mejor
forma de vida huyendo de la inseguridad
de la violencia desde luego también la
pobreza y soportando además ahorita a
temperaturas que ascienden a los 35
grados centígrados aquí en esta frontera
de tijuana con san diego california
estado
[Música]
desde hace años que turquía es conocida
como una de las mayores rutas
migratorias que llevan desde brenta
medio hasta europa todos conocemos y
recordamos esos años de 2015 y 2014 y
2016 cuando más de un millón de sirios y
también algunos cientos de miles de
iraquíes llegaron a europa a través de
las costas de turquía en dirección a
grecia la ruta de los balcanes que les
llevaba a alemania la ruta esta se ha
terminado pero turquía sigue siendo un
foco de migración para llegar a europa
ahora no son sirios los que llegan a
turquía sino que son afganos que huyen
del conflicto que les está azotando
ahora mismo en el país central de asia
central a través de la guerra entre el
gobierno de kabul y los talibanes la
ruta es algo distinta ahora los los
afganos no entran desde su resurgir sino
que entran desde el este después la ruta
sigue siendo la misma
grecia para llegar a europa sin embargo
grecia les bloquea y las llegadas al
continente europeo se han frenado
muchísimo en los últimos años
[Música]